EDHRE is a tool that collects deck data
from across the internet and which
creates pages for each commander that
contain the cards commonly played in
them. I have spoken before about how
using EDHRE for all of your deck
building needs can lead to decks that
are flat, formulaic, and missing lots of
great tools. And I've also spoken about
how lots of people building decks mostly
with EDHRE causes a handful of
unintended side effects for the broader
commander ecosystem. These things are
true and I stand by them. But I've also
seen some players take things too far in
the opposite direction, decrying EDRE as
a useless tool for anybody but the least
creative deck builders and giving
themselves a hearty pat on the back for
staying away from it. In reality, EDAR
is an intensely useful website that has
the capability to make your decks
better, more interesting, even more
unique in some ways if you know how to
use it correctly. So, in this video, I
want to dial in on EDHREC as a tool and
talk about how I use it, when during
deck building I use it, what specific
features I use, and things I like to be
careful of to prevent unintended
consequences. To start with, there are
two main times when I use EDHREC during
deck building. Very early in the process
of building a deck and then sporadically
closer to the end of deck building.
These two time frames serve very
different purposes. Early in the process
of deck building, I just want to get a
lay of the land. EDHER is useful as a
shortcut for seeing the most popular and
often the most powerful stuff you can do
with a commander. In some cases, these
will be the flashiest plays you can do
with a given commander. We can see Fists
of Flame at the top of the Zada page,
Curiosity at the top of the Nivemizette
Peroon page, and Parhelion II at the top
of the Gree Fang page. Even if you don't
intend to use the stuff at the top of an
EDHRE page, it's good to know what's
there. If you're looking to build a deck
around Anomar, a popular commander, it's
good to know that more than half of
Anomar players are playing him as some
form of combo deck, because that will
impact how your deck is perceived and
what other players will be on the
lookout for. In other cases, the top of
an EDH wreck page might be more like the
points of agreement between different
builds of a commander. For something
like Attra unifier, we see some popular
removal spells and some flicker cards to
repeat the commander's powerful ETB. But
after that, the play rates of different
cards fall off pretty fast with players
choosing a variety of different
approaches for the specifics of their
deck. In this case, I could go, okay,
I'll guess I'll start with flicker and
then decide the specifics of how I want
to do that. And if I want to be among
the roughly 25% of CEDH players playing
Atraxa, judging by this page, typically
I'll look at an EDA trek page at first
to see any super obvious build paths
that other people have been doing. But
then once I've decided to build a
particular commander, I'll click away
for a while. It's useful to know the
basics of what other people are doing.
But the longer you spend on this
unaltered EDH wreck page without looking
elsewhere, the more you'll get sucked
into the stuff on this page and
subconsciously let it decide what your
deck wants to be for you. In cases when
I'm using a top- down approach to build
a deck, basically finding a commander I
like with a card or two in mind, I like
to get out of EDH pretty early so that
the foundations of the deck aren't too
influenced by what's popular. In the
early stages of building a deck, I don't
really want to know that 47% of others
players are using Deadly Dispute because
that colors my opinion of the card at a
stage in deck building when I want to be
exploring possibilities and keeping an
open mind to different options with the
commander. Other players might be
different, but I find that the
progression of gradually building up in
cards and plugging in different Scryfall
searches as I figure out different ways
the deck could play is really valuable
as a creative step. It's a stage in deck
building that I want to preserve as much
as possible. Regardless of your exact
preferences, if you're starting your
deck building journey on EDHRE, I
strongly recommend you click away to
fuss around with your own thing for a
while at some point. For me, EDHRE comes
back into the picture a bit later once
I've discovered a fair number of cards
and have a decently strong concept of my
deck, but haven't fully ironed out an
initial draft yet. Whereas the initial
usage of EDH was to get a lay of the
land and see a handful of basic build
paths, in this later stage of EDHREC
usage, I am looking for specific cards.
Scrifall is a lovely tool, but there are
some things that it just won't hit in
any reasonable number of searches. Daort
mage won't show up in any common
searches you might make for a flicker
deck. And if you're building a caramera
deck, self bouncers like white main lion
might not even enter your radar if
you're not already in the know. This is
where EDH is helpful. It can help you
fill in the gaps with popular cards that
Skyfall searches might have missed. Even
if a particular card isn't showing up on
the EDH page due to not being popular
enough, looking at EDHR can still help
you find that card. If you're building a
cast from exile deck, you'll probably
find a bunch of payoffs for casting
things from exile from skyfall searches
on your own. But a brief trip to the
Prosper EDH track page might clue you in
on the words from anywhere other than
your hand. Suddenly, that's a whole new
avenue to take a stroll down, and you
might find yourself a lovely memory
worm. Get in here, you funky little guy.
Okay, so at this point, you hopefully
have a good idea of when I like to use
EDHRE and why I use it at those times.
Deck building is a very personal process
and you may have your own preferences,
but ideally you'll be starting to get a
better sense of what role the website
should have in your deck building.
However, in covering the when and the
why, I've so far skipped over the how,
arguably the most important part. This
might be confusing to a lot of people
because on a basic level, EDHRE is very
easy to use. You pop open the website,
find your commander, and you're off to
the races. Easy as cake, right? Wrong.
This page sucks if you're looking for
card choices for your specific deck
because it includes every deck for a
commander, even plenty that look nothing
like the one you're trying to build. I
think we as EDH players have a tendency
to treat commanders as whole entities,
like characters selected from a grid in
a fighting game. This game is Carter
versus Zur versus Sir Conrad versus one
of the 63 Kellins. What a legendary
matchup. Wanting to simplify this one
thing is an understandable impulse given
the intense complexity of the commander
format, but sadly it's an incorrect
impulse. Decks with a given commander
can vary dramatically from one another.
And the more diverse a given commander's
decks are, the less helpful the base EDH
page will be. So, what's the solution?
The answer is filters, which I make very
heavy use of once I'm further along and
in that card gleaning stage of EDHR
usage. By default, the website will draw
data from all decks in its database for
a given commander. But the filters
option allows you to filter out decks
that do or don't include a given card.
Now, you could put all sorts of stuff in
this, but the most useful type of card
will be what I like to call indicator
cards, which are basically just cards
that fit very cleanly in or out of a
given archetype. For example, if we go
to the page of Kellen Inquisitive
Prodigy, we see a mlange of different
elements, but the most prominent ones
are things involving clues, which kind
of makes sense given that green blue
clues is an established Innistrad
archetype. This is going to be helpful
to some people, but what if I'm looking
for a higher curved deck? Maybe even
considering the inclusion of Kuruga as a
companion. In that case, this page won't
do much for me before a bit of
filtering. And the one card near the top
of the page that really stands out as a
big mana option is Map the Frontier, a
four- mana sorcery that searches up two
basic lands and/or deserts to the field.
And actually, this works great as an
indicator card because it's not the sort
of card that most decks will want. Mana
ramp past two, maybe three mana stuff
will typically only be included in a
deck if it fits with the deck's
synergies. So, the presence of more
expensive ramp will generally be a good
sign that a deck has a big mana game
plan. Sure enough, that's reflected
after filtering. We see lots of higher
cost cards that would require mana
investment to succeed, as well as lots
of great tools for a Karuga deck. So,
that's one example, but what about an
example of an anti-indicator card? A
while back, I was brewing a Carter
control deck, sort of like a red flicker
deck. A major goal of the deck is to
have a basically unlimited supply of
disrupt decorums available since Carter
has that effect on ETB and ETBs can be
repeated with a card like Jaxis that can
produce a token copy of a creature each
turn. I thought this was a sensible
enough plan for the commander, but when
I went to the EDH page, a number of the
more commonly played cards themselves
did go related things. Initially, I was
pretty shocked that around half of all
Cardier players felt the need to run
cards that do the same thing as their
commander. But that's their business,
not mine. The important thing is what
happened next. I filtered the results.
One option could be to filter by cards I
know I want in the deck, such as a
couple red flicker staples like Jaxis
and Conjurer's Closet. However, the
result is pretty muddy with disrupt
decorum now showing up in an even
greater proportion of decks. The issue
is that these red flicker cards don't do
anything to indicate a player who is
averse to redundancy as I am to some
extent. There are plenty of code maxers
out there who will take the flicker
stuff and the additional copies of code
cards because they just like disrupting
decorum that much. No, the way to start
sculpting a helpful EDA track page in
this case is to exclude the cards that
do the same thing as the commander, such
as disrupt decorum and geodraer. And
after that, the page starts looking a
lot more helpful. There's still some of
this that's probably outside what my
deck would want to do, but at least the
good stuff is mostly out of the way.
Vengeful Ancestor is only in 12% of the
remaining decks after this filtering,
down from 43% on the base page. As a
final example of filtering, let's talk
about how to combine includes and
excludes. Back when I had a Lea hate
bears stack, I'd periodically check EDHR
to see if anything was catching my eye.
But for this to work, I needed to filter
the page first. The most popular build
of Leia is Life Gain. And though I don't
mind a little life gain to offset
Leasa's drain, it's definitely not what
the deck is built around. A first step
could be excluding some core life gain
cards such as Soul Warden, but this
isn't all that effective because life
gain is just such a dominant archetype
and there are plenty of life gain decks
not including a certain life gain card
for one reason or another. A different
approach is to filter for inclusion of
Thalia Guardian of Thrabin, which is
basically the first card I'd add to any
hate bears deck. And this is a bit more
effective, but life gain cards still
start creeping in at around 25%
inclusion. What works best is the
combined approach. If I filter for decks
that include Thalia and exclude soul
warden, life gain is basically
obliterated from the page with a well of
lost dreams and two sanguin bond effects
being the only life gain payoffs
remaining on the page. This also still
leaves a healthy 550 decks since I
didn't need to throw a whole bunch of
cards into my filters in order to get
the desired results. You can do
something similar with price. If you're
looking for a budget deck, if a base EDH
wreck page is helpful, aside from the
cards being too pricey, you could
exclude an expensive card and include
something cheap like a solid budget
land. Suddenly, the cards on the page
will be much more in your budget. It
becomes more clear just how important
filtering is when you think about an EDH
page as a cross-section of a handful of
different overlapping decks. Some
commanders will be pretty
straightforward and less diverse. If we
go to the Prosper EDHR page, there are
almost 30 non-land cards that show up in
more than 50% of Prosper decks.
Meanwhile, if we look at a similarly
popular but more open-ended commander,
Ala Artful Provocator, that number is
less than half of that. And some
commanders like Glissa Sunslayer have
almost no cards above the 50% played
threshold. For commanders with a
singular, more streamlined play path,
the base EDH wreck page can be
moderately helpful. But for a more
diverse commander, the page might be
pure soup, an unfiltered mishmash of
different archetypes interspersed across
the page. I actually made a video last
year about exactly these sorts of
commanders with Archalos, Francisco
Malcolm, and Skeleton Ship as examples.
The EDA trek pages of these commanders
are equal parts interesting to dig into
and instructive for seeing the limits of
an unfiltered EDA trek page. I'm also
very interested in what causes a
commander's EDA trek page to be more
diverse or less diverse. So, I actually
ended up working with my brother to
analyze a whole bunch of EDHREC pages,
and we made a whole video about it over
on my second channel, complete with a
tool to analyze your own commanders.
I'll include a preview of that at the
end of this video. Regardless of what
exact commanders you're using, filters
are an important thing to have in your
repertoire if you're using EDHER. The
website as a whole is a very useful
tool, both for getting a sense of the
broader play rates of a commander and
for finding specific cards. But if
you're using it for the latter purpose,
using filters will save you a lot of
time and effort and also show you more
cards. EDA trek pages will typically
show about 300 cards. And that's a
decent amount if most of the cards are
ones you'd actually consider. But if 2/3
of them are for disparate archetypes
that you didn't put in the effort to
filter out, suddenly you're getting a
lot less useful information out of the
page. So use filters. They're good. As a
final note, using EDHREC in general will
likely help your deck out in some form,
but I found that getting the best usage
out of it requires some level of
detachment from the website. Using other
resources and giving yourself a chance
to feel out where your deck wants to go
will help in giving your ideas room to
breathe away from the constant input of
how popular cards are. When you are
using EDA Track, it's useful to
sometimes take a step back and remember
what the information on your screen is
telling you. The stuff at the top of an
EDA track page is simply the stuff that
a bunch of people decided should go in
their deck. Different people might be
building decks in different ways and for
different reasons than you are. So, a
card being up there isn't necessarily a
positive or negative statement about it,
but it is a very informative one. Even
just taking a bit to think to yourself
about why a given card might be present
at a certain position on the page and
what sorts of decks it might be played
in is a really helpful exercise that
will make you a lot better at processing
the stuff that's on your screen. and
better at understanding the EDH
ecosystem in general. Any tool will be
much more useful to you if you can get a
sense of why it's doing exactly what
it's doing. Thanks for watching and
thanks to EDHRE for sponsoring this
video. I also want to thank Architect
for their ongoing support of the channel
and its integration of EDRE salt scores
and user pulled combo database can
provide interesting tools for seeing how
other people might see your deck.
Additionally, I want to thank my patrons
and YouTube members for their support,
some of whom are on screen now. As a
final note, the Command Zone just put
out a super fun and high ever video a
couple days ago to go with Edge of
Eternities, and you should definitely
check it out if you haven't already. A
link to that is in the description. With
that said, here's a preview of the
EDHREC Analyzer video, which will be
over on my second channel, also linked
in the description. Get a started
answering those questions. I partnered
with my brother Ian, who's much better
at coding than I am, to build a tool
that can give me some information about
an ED track page and compare it to
others. The end product was this a tool
where you can input a commander and it
ranks it on a few different metrics.
Let's jump over to Ian to talk us
through the basics. So now there are a
few different metrics this is analyzing,
right? You've got entropy, synergy, and
hipster cards. Do you want to just go
through those?
>> Yeah. So first up is entropy. And that
is a fancy data science term for the
like variation and chaos within a data
set. So really what it's looking at is
how unpopular the average card is. So
like it's a logarithmic scale. So 1.0 is
like the average card is played at a 50%
rate. 2.0 is the average card is played
at a 25% rate. And it's just a good
measure for
how much a deck is concentrated on
one main archetype or if it's spread out
amongst a bunch of different themes.